hassan connaît
bonjour merci d'être vous êtes en direct
du sénégal avec nous par téléphone ce
matin pour parler de cette situation au
burkina faso
confirmation du coup d'état militaire
hier à la télévision nationale pour
quelles raisons selon vous ce coup
d'état militaire at il eu lieu
je vous ai déjà eu en fait
le propos pour plusieurs raisons je
pense que
l'armée burkinabè était un peu exaspéré
depuis un certain temps par l'incapacité
du pouvoir burkinabè de g7 problème
c'est problématique sécuritaire qui ne
cesse de faire des victimes un peu
partout tendre dans le pays et
ses
militaires depuis tout ce temps le van
dyck des problèmes de salaires des
problèmes de primes des problèmes
d'équipement mais aussi des problèmes
logistiques
je pense que les événements que
oui oui je vous en prie poursuivez
donc ses terres en fête et les mets les
plus hautes de 2 7 me qui s'est
déclenchée le dimanche matin avoir de
nouveaux cas et voit le bouillant et
l'élargissement de ce malaise qui
couvait dans l'armée burkinabée depuis
depuis depuis tout ce temps et le car la
tactique natale passer
de ces carences dans la gestion de cette
problématique surtout dans le plan
logistique et les militaires notamment
les cadres officiers du bukina aussi sa
santé depuis l'arrivée du président roch
kaboré un peu écarté où il suscite une
méfiance que le président avait par
rapport à nos cadres militaires que si
tu faisais que le les contacts n'étant
pas bien établi entre cette hiérarchie
militaire est là
l'autorité politique et poétique les les
affaires de l'armée ne marchait pas de
la manière dont les soldats attendent et
c'est tout c'est tout c'est tout ce
mécontentement qui se sont cristallisées
et qui ont fait que les militaires
burkinabè ont décidé donc de passer à
l'action est-ce que là est selon vous la
situation est similaire à ce qui s'est
passé au mali on sait que le burkina
faso le mali et le niger font partie de
ces pays des trois frontières là où
justement il y à une des problèmes de
djihadisme islamique est ce que est ce
que c'est comparable ces deux situations
selon vous
en fait la situation s'est passé au
mobile à face au seul parlement qui a
motivé le coup d'état le sens le bon
goût plus à ce qui s'était passé au mali
en 2012 bien que dernièrement au mali
nous faut partir du principe aussi que
c'est que c'est la mobilisation qui
s'est passé quand le présent et bk est
aussi le pluie de là aussi bien d'une
mauvaise gouvernance politique mais
aussi d'une mauvaise gouvernance
sécuritaire mais il est certain que ce
qui s'est passé au burkina est ce que
s'est passé au mali on pousse souhaitant
tous de cette problématique sécuritaire
c'est la cape l'incapacité des
gouvernants de ces deux pays à gérer ce
problème sécurité qui ont pris un
certain nombre de problèmes parce que
c'est l'église qui était aussi au début
des crises purement sécuritaires qui
sont devenus dimensionnelle puis la
mauvaise gestion que les autorités dans
les deux pays avaient et c'est ça qui a
cristallisé aussi bien le mécontentement
au sein des militaires aussi le corps
cette relation et c'est ça qui a conduit
évidemment âgées et pourtant ces deux
pays sont soutenus par par la france
notamment avec la force par ken qui est
engagée dans le sahel c'est l'échec
aussi de cette politique de soutien
internationale occidentale en tout cas
ces deux pays africains pour dans la
lutte contre le djihadisme
je ne dirais pas que c'est l'échec de
l'échec de cette action de
statut militaire parce que vous
comprenez la publicité avec la france a
à raconter à ces pays le mali d'abord à
travers l'opération sa vie s'est
transformée en 2014 à l'opération
barclays qui l a pris tout le temps de
le faire avec 5000 soldats et vous savez
que le jeu ne scellent ah c'est pas un
petit terrain de bosses il
s'est appuyé à apporter beaucoup de
choses
très bon travail a eu de très bons
résultats
il y a eu beaucoup de mattel qui a été
détruit mais il vous faut se dire que
on a dit soir c'est bart and we
nationale
du goût qui se
base sur un modèle exceptionnel et qui
arrivent à se régénérer qui ont
développé
et qui fait qu' il s'agit c'est vrai que
les populations ne perçoit pas parce
qu'elles sont toujours les attaques
fusent toujours elle compte toujours les
morts ils comptent tous les déplacés et
elles sont les pressions on a pas de
fumée
l'opération a fait du travail
aussi bien que les forces nationales
comment vous expliquer le fait que le
mali par exemple hier à demander le
départ immédiat des des forces spéciales
danoise des 90 hommes qui ont été
déployés par le danemark récemment
selon le communiqué que j'ai vus de
toute manière c'est qu'elle le dise ne
pas avoir formé vous savez ces derniers
temps avec la situation qui prévaut au
mali les autorités avec la fermeture des
frontières avec tout ce qui se passe
elles sont devenues un peu un peu le
signal
peut être informés ou bien
alors qu'auparavant les choses même les
estime qu'en l'état doit former ou
je ne sais plus difficile la vie est
longue et maintenant avec les militaires
au mali et peut-être prochainement au
burkina faso
un dialogue politique dès que les états
dialogue avec ces pays non s'il pense
qu'il va prouver n'ai pas de problème il
suffit de pouvoir prendre en avait créé
puis de de parler d'eux sur un certain
nombre de choses et de s'entendre sur
certaines choses et ensuite de le parler
parce que eux ils ont l'impression
qu'ils ne sont bien manque de
considération dans les dents dans ce qui
se passe je pense que il ya une manière
d'imposer également aux maliens
oui les sanctions qui ont été imposées
ces des sanctions c'est la sanction
habituelle à l'est la laisse plus de
coup d'état mais ça n'exclut pas des
sanctions et n'exclut pas que le
dialogue puisse toujours être établie et
au burkina faso on entend aussi la
population demandé le départ des forces
occidentales est ce que c'est
majoritaire selon vous
cet appel au départ il est
perceptible au sein des populations
parce que vous savez un peu avec tous
ces problèmes de réseaux sociaux et tout
ça maintenant les populations sont un
peu
plus ou moins jeudi manipuler c'est un
plat c'est parce qu'on leur fait
comprendre que ces forces
internationales se sont et qu'il y avait
eu lors de la mini ce manque il ya 5000
ans il y a la faute à
pas et qui vient corriger 5 et que tout
ça n'apporte pas de résultats donc c'est
devenu un peu le l'exutoire il faut
trouver quelqu'un alors cesser ces
messieurs je ne pense pas que ce soit
comme licite ailleurs le reste en bas
sur la dernière fois ci si les forces
internationales sélectif l'association
ça l'à beaucoup plus compliquée qu'elle
n'est aujourd'hui s'annonce tout où les
puissances que pensez vous de la
situation actuellement au burkina faso
est ce que ça va se passer sans heurt
selon vous
je pense que je pense que le coup d'état
qui s'est passionné face au chili il est
plus ou moins acceptée aussi bien par le
public que par parler par les militaires
parce que je vous disais que l'armée en
général la majorité des hauts cyprès qui
n'avait que vous rencontrez qu on en
compterait
10 est réellement que le président le
gouvernement de d'euros kaboré n'a pas
réussi à gérer cette affaire et qu'il
fallait qu'il y ait un changement il ne
parlait pas de coup d'état mais c'est
vers ça que ça finit par aboutir et je
pense qu'il n'y avait pas de là pas de
maintenant c'est sûr que lille va encore
tête sous les sanctions comme le mali et
le je pense que
un pays sous sanction on n'est pas des
tapis digital qu'il n'est pas sous
sanction n'allait pas s'en sortir alors
s'il est sous sanction je ne sais pas
comme comment ça va se passer
ça va être très difficile je ne sais pas
trop si
comment la combattre en ce sens elle va
gérer ce problème un contenu inédit six
pays là parce qu'en fait c'est des pays
qui sont pauvres c'est des pays qui sont
enclavés ces deux pics sont très
dépendants de l'extérieur et qui avec
aussi il année où la pluviométrie et n'a
pas été très bonne si les pays qui ont
encore long comment des difficultés
maintenant
je ne sais pas comment laisser ces
terres là vont s'en sortir alors
question sociale sion ils ont besoin
vraiment de on va voir cela merci
beaucoup à ça le connaît d'avoir répondu
ce matin en direct dakar à nos questions
sur rt france